PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Hi,
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and this is AI
Simplifed, where we
learn to make our data useful.
In this series,
we've been learning
about ingesting data,
training models, and getting
predictions.
It would be handy to learn how
to automate all of these tasks
by implementing them
programmatically.
In this video, we will
learn how to do exactly
that with the Vertex AI SDK.
Now, before we
dive into the SDK,
let's take a quick
look at the options
to interact with Vertex AI.
There is Google Cloud Console.
It is the UI to work with
our model assets, the data
sets, the endpoints, and
the predictions in Cloud.
Now, so far we've been using
the console in this series,
so you must be familiar.
But if not, I've included the
links to the previous episode
below.
Now, anything that you
can do through the UI,
you can also do
programmatically.
And for that, we have the
Google Cloud Vertex AI SDK.
And then there are Vertex
AI client libraries,
which help us make calls
to the Vertex AI API.
Now, the benefits of
using client library
is that they are
optimized for languages
that you choose to use--
for example, Java,
Python, or Node.
Now the question becomes
when to use the console
and when to use the SDK.
The UI helps us get familiar
with the features and functions
available in Vertex AI.
So for that reason, using the
UI is my go-to recommendation
if you are new to
machine learning and AI,
or just prefer to
do things visually.
The SDK is best
if you're looking
to programmatically implement
the steps in your ML workflow.
Now, if you are an experienced
machine learning engineer
or data scientist,
then you would
benefit from the ease of
automating your workflow.
If SDK isn't available in
the language of your choice,
then you can use the client
libraries or the REST API.
Now that we know the different
ways to interact with Vertex
AI, we need a fun example
to play with and create
a model using the SDK.
I've picked out the
perfect data set for this--
beans.
Well, who does not like beans?
Being a math nerd, I found
out that Pythagoras--
yeah, the one who came up
with a squared plus b squared
equals c squared,
that Pythagoras--
had an aversion to beans.
Who would have thought, right?
OK, so here's the game plan.
Overall, we will get the
data, explore it a little bit,
then create a
model and deploy it
to an endpoint from which
we can make predictions.
And we will do all of
this using the SDK.
We will need the tools
to explore the data
and prototype this ML model.
Now for this, we
will use notebooks
within Vertex, which is the
hosted JupyterLab Notebooks.
They come preinstalled with
your favorite machine learning
workflows, such as
TensorFlow or PyTorch.
These frameworks are
already installed,
and you also have
customized hardware,
so you can use the CPUs and
the GPUs if you need it.
It also integrates with Git, so
we can customize and initialize
a Git repo within the
notebook, and it also
integrates with other
Google Cloud services.
So we'll put our
data into BigQuery,
which is Google Cloud
enterprise data warehouse,
and inside the notebook,
we will download that data
from BigQuery and
then put it into use
to explore that data
using pandas DataFrame.
And then the next step would
be to create our training
job, creating the
Vertex AI model,
deploying it, and then
making predictions,
and then finally monitoring
that job in the console.
Now, ready to go?
Let's see it.
Now in the Vertex AI console,
we can create a hosted Jupyter
Notebook.
And if we click
on a New Instance,
we see that there are
different types of notebooks
that we can choose from.
They come preinstalled with
our favorite machine learning
frameworks, and we can add
GPUs if needed, and can also
install additional libraries
after the notebook is created.
I've already created a notebook
here, so let's get into it.
The first step is to
download our data.
I'm using Dry Beans Dataset from
UCI, which I have linked below.
This is a tabular
data set that was
taken from images for
different types of beans,
and different data points were
collected on each type of bean.
In manufacturing and
other industries,
it's common to extract
tabular metadata from images
and use that to train a model.
I've already uploaded
the data in BigQuery,
and we can see the different
data points in the schema.
The label that we are
predicting is called Class,
and we can run this
[? quick ?] query
in the data set to see roughly
what the distribution of bean
type is across our data set.
So here, I'm using the
BigQuery client library
to download that data inside my
notebook as pandas DataFrame.
And using this
pandas method, we can
see a plot of how the data
is distributed by parameters.
Next, we use the Seaborn library
to create a pair plot, which
can help us identify
our relationships
between the features in
our data and the label
column within the class.
Now that we have a good idea
of what our data looks like
and how it is balanced,
we are ready to kick off
the training job in Vertex AI.
We initialize the project
that we want to use.
Then to train this
model using AutoML,
we first need a data set.
We can pass the URL to
the data in BigQuery
directly to Vertex AI.
There's no need to
manually move our data--
Vertex will handle that for us.
Now if we go in Vertex AI
console into our data set,
we can see our
created data set here
and then we can
see more details,
such as the schema and the
data source in BigQuery.
We could kick off the
training job here,
but I trust that you
can click a button,
so let's stick to
the SDK for this one.
Back in our notebook,
here is the code
to create the training job.
This is a classification
model, where we are classifying
the beans into seven classes.
So we define that and pass
all the different features
that we want to use in
training this model.
You could add more
options here, such as how
you would want
AutoML to optimize
the training, specifically
useful for an imbalanced data
set.
I'm not doing that here.
Finally, job.run will
run the training job.
We specify the data set
we want to use, the target
column or label that we are
predicting, how long we want
to run the training for,
and enable early stopping,
so Vertex AI stops the
training if it does not
see that the model can
be further improved.
Now you specify this, which is
useful to keep the cost low.
Once the model has trained--
this could take some time--
we can see in the console that
the training job has finished.
And we can see the
evaluation metrics
to see how our model
actually performed.
The confusion matrix shows
how good a job our model
did in distinguishing
the different bean types.
Since this is a tabular
model, Vertex AI
also gives us feature importance
out of the box with AutoML.
We can see the features
in our data set
that signaled our model's
prediction the most.
Here, it looks like shape
and eccentricity were
the most important features.
Now that we have
our model created,
let's deploy our
endpoints so we can
use it to serve predictions.
You can do that
right here in the UI,
but let me show you how
to do that in the SDK.
All you have to do
to deploy the model
is model.deploy and the type of
machine type you want to use.
There are more things
you can specify here,
but I'm just going
with a minimum.
Once created, we can
see it in the console
and test to make predictions
from our endpoint.
Let's head back over
into our notebook
and see how to make
predictions using the API.
We provide a test set.
Then we need to create
the endpoint object,
grab the resource name from the
deployed model and use it here,
and then we use that
to make a prediction
request to our endpoint.
And there's our prediction.
We just trained an AutoML
model and made a prediction
using the SDK.
We could use the same data set
to train a custom model, too,
all using the SDK.
Here are the code samples
that can help you do that.
Try it out yourself.
And if you need help,
refer to the links below.
All right, so today we created
a bean classification model
using the Vertex AI Python SDK.
Give this a try
yourself, and let
me know how it goes
in the comments below.